hello everyone and welcome to the other
part of the semi-finals in the feeder
Grand Prix 2019 it's yummy ponies vs.
Lavoie - ik as you've seen I was angry
she eliminated Hikaru Nakamura in the
semi-final so Bishop is the first
finalist and now we will see who is the
other one
so a prior to this five games have ended
in a draw between Nepal and Roddick
first two Callaspo games then - rapid
games the 25-minute once and then the
110 minute to rapid game so this is the
other one where Knepper now has the
white pieces and radical has to hold
hold it to go into blitz and then maybe
even Armageddon so we do have one photo
compliments of Nikki Riga there you have
it it's not from this game it's from the
previous one as the hero Roddick has the
white pieces but there we have it
everything is in order Knepper has his
little chunky bottle of water rather who
did not bring any refreshments which can
often be you know a fatal mistake as you
know when things you really get heated
up during a chess game you definitely
want some refreshments either in some
nice water or at least some light juice
okay that being said let's check out
this very nice game a nipple with the
white pieces opens with E 4 we have C 5
the Sicilian defense Knight f3 d6 and
now Bishop to b5 check the rosalie mo
with Knight to d7 blocking and now d4
seek a person d4 Queen captures on d4 as
the knight has already been developed
here the knight cannot come to c6 to
attack the Queen so you will not be
losing any Tempe here with a6 either
pushing the bush or back or offering
your trade here Knepper says okay Bishop
capture some b7 Bishop capture some d7
and not nice to see 3 so here what did
give up the bishop pair very early on
but he has a lot of development and well
it's a it's a quite an online that
everyone enjoys with the white pieces
and here a 5 by black here Alec doesn't
want to allow a nipple to charge with a
5 there is one game in the database it
was played some two weeks ago rook to
see it was played in even charge plated
with the black pieces against Gawain
Jones and the Jones immediately attacked
with E 5 and won a very nice game with
the white pieces but here if I first
pushing the Queen back
Queen to d3 and only now look to see it
and here we have castles buy an apple
with h6 buy black and now comes Knight
the d2 this Knight has some plans of
coming all the way to f1 and then
depending on what black plays either to
g3 or or e3 or or whatever you know
Queen to c7 and here there are a few
games in the database where I believe
there's one game in the database for
rook to e1 was played and there are
several rook to d1 was played rook to d1
being the main move and most notable
games being a linear Dominguez versus
Geoffrey Sheung which ended in a draw
and Luke McShane versus Neil's grand
alias where a local machine want a very
nice game with rook to d1 but here
nipple goes h3 and it is over this
moment move 11 that we have a completely
new game on our hands so let's see how
erotic deals with it and it's not not
the greatest position to be in you
you're in completely new position you
have to defend against nipple who is
just you know a beast with black pieces
and well it's a rapid game so there's
not all that much time to think about
stuff Knight to f6 developing you won't
play Bishop to e7
you know maybe Castle and do something
about your weak d6 pawn as you don't
want it to stay there forever with a for
my nipple preventing any beef Queen side
expansion from black also a5 might be an
idea grabbing even more space on the
Queen side Bishop to e7 and now rook to
d1 we have castles biotic and now Knight
to f1 so now you can see that's an echo
is starting he's manoeuvring with the
night and hieratic says okay you just
you know do your knight maneuvering but
i'm gonna play d5 and it's a very nice
idea it's a it's a well it can and might
not be a pawn sacrifice depends on what
white place but here Knepper grabs it
with ich a purse on d5 and now nice th
by Roddick preparing Knight to d6 to
create this very nice blockade he wants
to go Knight to d6 push f5 and then go
just you know II for f4 and start an
attack against the white team which if
you try something what's a 94 you're
gonna get Knight d6 and now even if you
trade the bishop captures you have to do
something about the c2 pawn as well for
example c3 now you're gonna get f5 and
black will get a lot of contra play for
this game
at porn but Knepper isn't interested in
that and you can see that he came very
well prepared with this line with white
pieces he gives the pawn back instantly
with d6
so what's the idea behind d6 well first
of all nipple now clears the d5 square
for his Knight and it's all I mean in
pretty much every line of the Sicilian
you want your knight on d5 either traded
on d5 or just to remain there with
Bishop characters on d6 now comes Knight
to d5 and now the sea dew point is
off-limits for the moment if you capture
capture capture then Knight can just
prevent it from escaping with Knight to
c3
next time we were gonna go 93 and you're
gonna pick up this rook well you're not
gonna pick it up black we'll have to
give it up for a let's say a bishop so
you will win the exchange so after
Knight to d5 we have Queen to c6 getting
the Queen out of out of the way and now
comes Knight if the e3 so this Knight
really had a very nice journey from g1
to f3 to D 2 to f1 and not to e3 guards
his you know companion on d5 and
protected the c2 upon a one more time so
now Roddick really has to decide what to
do time is ticking and he has to play
something Bishop to e6 is is an idea f5
is an idea starting to you know put the
pawns here but here he played Bishop to
c5 and it's a move that Believe It or
Not might cost him the game depending on
what nipple plays so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the move
nipple played it's a wonderful idea and
well we I mean I learned a lot from it I
hope you will too so you know feel free
to pause video and try to find the best
idea for white here I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it you are an excellent
trapper of bishops and for those of you
who just won't enjoy the show here are
never played before and now it all
starts to make sense now you see that
the bishop has to move but the bishop
has to move somewhere to always keep an
eye on the e7 squares play some Bishop
to a7 you get a 97 check and you lose
the Queen it's check and the game then
the game is over
on the other hand you could try to try
something like e for maybe grab some
space before deciding what to do with
the bishop but the white will just
ignore you
you're not gonna capture the pawn and
allow something like Queen t6 you're
just gonna go
Queeny - and now the game will continue
in pretty much the same way as it did in
the game so hereafter be for erratic
play Bishop to d6 and now comes C 4 and
C 4 would the idea of C 5 is really
strong the bishop will have to go
somewhere and you cannot go to e7
because then nothing guards the bishop
on e7 you will lose the bishop and the
Queen if that is played so erratic has
to figure out what to do we have b6 now
preventing c5 as now both the b-pawn and
the bishop protect the c5 square
but neppo just pushes a5 and yes it
seems that sometimes interest things are
this simple you want to remove the
defender of the c5 square so just a
capture sin b5 and b6 a terrible threat
which will be followed by c5 and you
know things are not good at looking good
for black here he'll rather cried efore
he tried to grab some space here
probably if Queen captures you want to
go f5 and f4 but never just ignored it
we have Queen to d4 now even with a
triple attack towards this pawn here
again if you capture it then c5 will win
the bishop so there's no way to to react
to this here rather finds a way to save
had to save the bishop and not lose any
pieces by playing Bishop to e6 but
nipple just grabs the poem with a cap
for some b6 Bishop captures on b5 now
Queen captures on d5 Queen captures on
d5 and now rook captures on b5 attacking
the the bishop here but okay the Knight
is guarding it the bishop just grabs the
pawn with but some characters on d4 and
now rook captures an a6 and now after
you count everything it would seem that
okay black didn't lose any pieces it's a
bishop it's a nice and Bishop against
the bishop and night but white does have
two connected pass pawns on the Queen
side they're not connected yet but they
you know they might be so here we have
Knights the d6 and here nipple just
plays b7 he says I don't mind you
capturing my pawn here because the rook
is under attack if you move the rook
then you get either rook captures here
you can give up the rook for a knight
and the bishop or just rook to b6
defended and then you're gonna push see
a story c5 c6 and and win the game but
here after but after we
seven erotic captured the pond and buddy
doesn't help him as never just played
rook to b6 and it was in this position
that I rather saw void resigned the game
he resigned because he either loses a
knight or a bishop and he has no no
compensation whatsoever for any of it
and you know being down a piece in a
name game against any Grandmaster is in
itself you know a defeat
but against someone like Jana Palma she
it really really makes no sense so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and here I was thinking about using
something nepos said after the game that
when they asked him what does he expect
from the finals as now he will face
Alexander Bishop in the finals and they
said he said that the the one thing he
expects the most from the finals is
Alexander Greeks interview after after
the finals as you know Grisha was always
on fire during the giving of the
interviews
however they are gonna it's gonna be a
really an awesome fight I really hope it
doesn't end in the classical time format
I really hope they go into Rapids and it
may be even even blitz it's gonna be
gonna be just awesome so yeah once again
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Nicholas Dale
Clark barbi and Josiah Foster for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals of the feeder Grand Prix 2019
continuing the Chester's brawls or
whatever it's called tournament at the
little indoors whiskey distillery with
you know Carson ding Island and insert a
hurricane well at some point we will
continue the capo Blanca saga and of
course checking up on your suggestions
so that's it I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Saturday